learning new details about the planning
of the attack cbs news has reviewed more
than 600 pages of messages the alleged
gunman is believed have written on the
social media platform discord the
accused shooter has pleaded not guilty
jeff pigues has the story
messages on discord dating back more
than five months appear to show the
suspected shooters plot to kill as many
black people as he could in a december
post he promised to carry out an attack
against those he slurred as replacers
a month later he uploaded a picture of
an assault rifle he allegedly bought at
this store and used in saturday's racist
killing spree
by early march the alleged gunman
identified the top supermarket as
attacked area one where he planned to
shoot all blacks later that month posts
show that he scoped it out in person and
uploaded hand-drawn maps of the grocery
store discord says that it has an
internal team that works to identify and
remove extremist content like hate
speech and threats of violence but the
platform has around 150 million monthly
users it would have been very difficult
for anyone outside of his direct
community to find or interact with his
posts cbs news technology reporter dan
patterson says part of discord's appeal
is that it offers users privacy
the alleged shooter seemed to take
advantage of that
according to a spokesman for discord he
was posting to a private invite only
channel a small group was ultimately
invited to it just half an hour before
the shooting began in order for law
enforcement to see content in a site
like discord or even private facebook
groups they would have to be in that
group at a particular time not only are
there legal prohibitions there's the
practicality
of saying how do we collect that retired
fbi agent catherine schweitz used to run
the agency's active shooter program
she compares finding hateful post online
to searching for a grain of sand at the
beach unless the american people get
their head out of the sand and find a
way to be aware of their children their
neighbors and their coworkers we're
never going to solve this problem
the discord spokesperson told us the
company is doing everything it can to
help law enforcement in this
investigation the company also said that
there is no place for hate on the
platform gail there's no place for hate
anywhere actually thank you very much
jeff